- I never wanted to do an episodic sitcom.
In fact, it's a secret
that has finally come out.
I was asked to play the role of Frasier.
I turned it down 'cause I
didn't want to do a sitcom.
Then along came this pitch meeting
for 3rd Rock From The Sun.
Bonnie and Terry Turner,
this husband-and-wife
comedy writing team who created 3rd Rock,
they had been on the writing
staff of Saturday Night Live
two of the three times I was
a guest host in the 1980s.
So they wrote comic revue
material that I performed,
and they saw me as a comic,
and they became very good friends.
My agent called me one day and said,
"Your friends from New York,
Bonnie and Terry Turner,
"want to have breakfast with you."
And I thought, great!
(audience laughing)
I'd love to see them!
So I went off thinking this
was a social engagement,
and there were Bonnie and Terry
and Carsey and Werner and Caryn Mandabach,
all these big-shot Hollywood
television producers
at the Four Seasons in Beverly Hills.
And I thought, oh my
god, I've been ambushed.
(audience laughing)
This is a pitch.
Course, they got around to saying
what they wanted at breakfast about.
They said, "Terry, why
don't you tell him?"
"Well, we're developing this series
"about these four aliens."
(audience laughing)
And I thought, "How am I just gonna say no
"as graciously as I can
and get out of here?"
Within five minutes, he persuaded me
to be in 3rd Rock From The Sun,
because, just exactly what you said,
it was an opportunity to surprise people
and be far, far more than any one thing,
even though it's only one character.
These were aliens who
were trying to figure out
how to be humans, so they kept
trying different approaches,
and trying to plumb the depths
of different human mysteries.
Well, that's what we're all doing,
and doing it in this
hilarious comedy context
with this great premise that allowed me,
a character actor, to just
do everything, week by week.